you got booked once to do some egg that
turned to be very different than what
you thought it was gonna be a private
gig I heard about this it's kind of
well-known but I'm just curious if you
tell it talked about yes okay I did I
got offered to do a private party at a
house and I said I don't do a private
party and then they called me back and
they said how much would it take there's
got to be a price and there was a price
and I told him the price and it was more
than most people make a year and they
said okay and then I said it sounds
weird cash and they went ok and they
delivered all this cash and it was way
up in the hills in the canyons here in
LA and I asked my wife if she wanted to
join me and she said no what I thought
and I'm driving up there and I in the
middle of the night I Drive up there and
there's a like a woman a scantily clad
woman in the middle of the street that
kind of stops my car and I go yeah she
goes are you Howie Mandel and I go yeah
this way this way I will take the car
and I get out of the car and we go
through the hedges and across the pool
and I hear some noise in the house and
everything and then I go in the pool
house I go and they said wait here until
you hear ladies and gentlemen Howie
Mandel and I'm in like a toilet I'm in
the toilet and and and well while I'm
standing there another man comes in I'm
right beside the bowl he comes in and
relieves himself like I'm not even there
right then because I'm supposed to be a
surprise I was facing the wall I don't
know what he thought yeah and then
within minutes
I hear Lidia I know I'm not the
attendant the comedian and then I hear
ladies and gentlemen Howie Mandel and I
open the door and there's like eight
guys there eight guys doing things
nobody had clothes on and there's eight
guys it's an orgy
it was orgy there was 16 women doing
things the guys going to the to the
potty voice do the Bobby's voice you
know and then I'll just tell you want
you to what they want it they're making
requests but but the thing is and I
thank God I didn't bring my wife but I
said why would they hire me and then it
was a week later I'm walking in a mall
here in LA and a wife comes up and says
you're Howie Mandel and I go yeah she
goes oh my husband told me they went to
a bachelor party two weeks ago and you
were the entertainment and I look
look like a hundred yards back in the
guy's born I was I was hired to be an
excuse
you want me you were to cover I like
that excuse you were the cover for the
whole thing I have that I am then they
cook they weren't lying
oh yeah what'd you do what did you do we
had Howie Mandel yeah yes you did you
had how he meant oh my god and talk
about a standing ovation
to happy crowd I've never had a show
that had a happy ending
you